man I've been bullshitting let me just
say something funny today um and by
funny I mean fucked-up and dark so here
we go are you ready you strapped in yeah
alright so I I've been watching stranger
things okay and it's some boo boo mm-hmm
that's not that's neither here nor there
I don't know you know you don't like it
no okay but yeah I already got season
four mapped out ready okay okay the gang
goes to Jeffery Epstein's Island mm-hmm
and 11 goes there and uses her mind
control to kill Drake because Drake is
planning to have a little forehead kiss
session and they gotta go kill his ass
[Laughter]
I'm not saying I'm not saying anything
I'm not gonna be the one I'm not gonna
be the the I'm not gonna be the codis
dude stop stop dude stop the dark
moments I'm just gonna like you got
anything else keep going that's pretty
great stranger things the open sores and
drink and ever seen together Drake's
like L I thought you'd never come here
now
thought you're just gonna leave me
hanging and Dustin's outside like hurry
we gotta kill Drake
damn they start push the tease the one
to drop him off yeah he's like yeah I
know
yeah thanks l he says mmm he's like
Groot yeah yeah he's on an island yeah I
don't know this [ __ ] season it's
stranger things so did the Dookie is it
it's just I didn't watch any of it so
this is like an it's um we'll get into
it with Spock later it's um this is a
Duke inator it's some Duke inator yeah
yeah I was
laughing at the really Bobby Brown just
getting a bloody nose and exploding
Drake's ballsacks yeah that's funny
that's funny
that's definitely for me that's a good
one yeah all right dude I've just the
[ __ ] corruption in I don't know the
case is so interesting just because of
how many people he's involved with and
[ __ ] like oh yeah buddy he's gonna deal
probably just make away let me apply
just gonna run away oh speaking of man
we got a lot because so much three go on
about come remind me about area 51 in a
second oh yeah right
we can talk about neural link after that
so I didn't watch anything about neural
link so that's why I wanted to talk
about it because I don't know [ __ ] and I
was like super faded like yeah yeah yeah
but anyway um yeah the sceen case it was
really funny to me huh it's not that I
go on reddit or anything yeah no no of
course not
what does it read it what was the
website thing is um I think it's like um
how do you read read read it read D di t
read EDI to read did it yeah okay I'm
just saying re d di - that's cool come
like a web 2.0 kind of name yeah that's
cool yeah re d di t it's a it's what
happened I teach I did it got it yeah
cool call IT tech folded this is their
new comfort gotcha okay here at re d di
t I learned how to staple this [ __ ]
not a staple grapes into my [ __ ]
[ __ ] learned how to argue with people
I learned how to shitpost derp derp P me
mr. peanut their pina memes I was done I
was bussing up at a fortnight cuz they
got a burger with its tongue out and he
was a sticker and that burger is just
called derp oh wow yeah I was like whoa
throwing it back wow that's some 90s and
sensitive everybody is damn it just derp
yeah
derpy dude yeah and then derp pinna and
derping along yeah yeah derp was just
like getting away with saying [ __ ]
basically yeah being mean yeah yeah yeah
we're gonna say anyway I don't
what the [ __ ] doesn't say I lost my
train of thought I'm blue ever [ __ ]
Epstein oh yeah I saw him in the
comments and I'm and I'm chuckling
because they were like oh he's gonna
some guys were talking about basically
if if they put him out on bail he's
gonna flee the country yeah cuz he has
the means to do it yeah and someone goes
oh and I with all his connections he'll
definitely get someone to help him get
his ankle monitor off without giving out
a signal I'm like bro hey look up
removing my ankle monitor on into Dhoni
people just do that [ __ ] like to be
funny
like there's a hell of videos of just
like [ __ ] just 20 year olds just like
yeah so I got an ankle monitor off some
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you got the same
thing and you just want to get out for a
few hours I'm gonna show you how to do
that hello tutorials like basically you
get like [ __ ] like a like the rap to
a 30 break you gonna fold it three times
put it in your ankle get a pen like this
and just off the shoe it goes it's good
for like two hours come back slip it on
the same way you're good fool holy [ __ ]
there's so many people do that [ __ ] yeah
that's pretty funny I was dying goes on
foods going wild there was a guy with an
ankle monitor they took a clip he's like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] full he just cuts it
doesn't it like start like going crazy
his pee oh definitely got alerted like
right away
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that's what a hilarious
man
yeah I was just chuckling into this
[ __ ] keyboard warrior thinks like he
has to like call in a favor to get an
ankle monitor yeah yeah bras it's like
[ __ ] this is like velcro just take it
off yeah it's just what you just take it
off then yeah yeah and now I mean uh
that guy's a piece of [ __ ] though mm-hmm
it's kind of did you watch the video of
the drone going over his island now that
[ __ ] was creepy as hell why it's just
creepy yeah just like you look at it and
like II just start to like imagine like
what kind of [ __ ] was going on there
yeah and it's like also the the island I
don't fully remember all the features of
but I want to say that was like a it's a
good giant like sundial which like looks
really weird and there's this little
house like err like modern
air-conditioning like built into the
roof and [ __ ] and it's like a really
strange looking house and just like a
compound type building it's just like
one road that kind of goes around it
it's creepy yeah it was just and you
know I can't even verify that that's the
island yeah but assuming it is yeah I
don't know even the idea that someone is
just like oh it's that one over there
and just flew a drone over there I don't
know I just freaked me out because it
could be something really [ __ ] like
it could just be like a sex dungeon or
something yeah like that yeah yeah with
yeah [ __ ] creepy yeah so very creepy
but it's it's shitty to know that
nothing's probably gonna happen to him
no he'll get someone will definitely
happen you think I think so yeah I don't
know man I feel like somebody have had
enough about the whole thing but piece
of [ __ ] like that just gonna get away
with it I can't believe I'm reading this
book right now about like Russian
oligarchs mm-hmm yeah darhk's oligarchs
right like who specifically that word
sounds absurd saying it right now am i
saying it wrong
oligarch oligarch yeah I think it's
right all this harsh don't worry someone
correct to you yeah definitely
this book's called red notice it's about
Bill Browder who was like he started a
hedge fund he's basically like the first
he's the biggest international investor
in Russia especially when Russia became
capitalist mmm-hmm and they started
privatizing all their all the companies
and stuff like that he was he was the
one to like buy like a crazy amount of
these vouchers that he could use to like
trade for stock in this company Wow and
they were all undervalued because that's
the way that they were privatizing
everything so he made like a [ __ ] ton of
money but essentially the way he made
all this money is by exposing Russian
oligarchs who bought all these companies
themselves for way cheaper and then
would sell pieces of them to like family
members and stuff for like mmm like
basically all of these people and their
family members became billionaires
overnight because they stole it all from
the piece oh my god and Putin's like the
biggest example of that he's worth some
like I mean bill says he's worth
something like 200 billion dollars
because
because he basically made a deal with
all these oligarchs being like I get 30%
of everything that you own and then
we're on the same team and you will
never get like prosecuted and blah blah
blah right was more to this than that
but I'm just like generalizing yeah and
and so basically bill got kicked out of
Russia over like no reason
uh-huh it's basically cuz he was
exposing all these people that were on
Putin's side right so he got kicked out
of Russia and then they put like like
I'm not like into the book very much yet
but they like kill his lawyer they
basically put it like a red notice which
was like a mmm it's kind of like a
international warrant to arrest someone
yeah that like people in the UN have to
like honor or something like that
okay I don't know the full story but
it's just crazy the amount of like
corruption the higher-level corruption
like Russia and places and it's like
similar to people like Epstein yeah he's
just gonna they know the right people
they can just they're above the law such
a [ __ ] such a crazy thing yet it's
[ __ ] nuts man and like and people
bringing up like that dude went to he
got caught on like whatever like a sex
trafficking like he got time yeah did
like a year and you're here and people
are like in jail for like [ __ ] weed
for like five years yeah 10 years yeah
[ __ ]
yeah to the fullest dude that's the
[ __ ] Illuminati dude is people like
that oh [ __ ] we're turning into Infowars
they're [ __ ] gates i mean i'm yeah
exactly
yeah I mean it's just they do that [ __ ]
though yeah and they just think they're
above the law ah yeah it's crazy there's
probably way more [ __ ] Epstein's out
there yeah who knows this is this is the
part of the podcast where it's like he's
so dick jokes you guys were talking
about before okay no no inside
don't worry the dark
[Music]